bom eu quero avisar vasco trazer
problemas mas é eo a coisa aqui da
metrópole e eu falo não está funcionando
isso pra lá não funcionou no agora então
seguinte
háháhá acho que atua pois não estão
colhendo bem as crianças eu vou falar de
escola de educação e também um pouco da
metrópole
num tom olhando bem ali era uma colina
não só as crianças e jovens o acolhem
bem ninguém só pensar eu fui pensando em
passar três horas de casa até o trabalho
com conforto sem conforto é muito pouco
saudável né e as crianças também levar
em mais de uma hora para chegar à escola
não só é pouco saudável como é uma perda
de tempo é de estar brincando estudando
bom o e as crianças convivem com esse
problema já que a tropa ele porque achei
que fez tanta tecnologia transformou o
planeta numa metrópole ana todos os
problemas mundiais estão na cidade
também conflitos políticos conflitos
étnicos conflitos religiosos conflitos
armados conflitos de classe poluição e
escassez de energia tudo tá na metrópole
e nós todos convivendo com isso na
metrópole né fora isso a tecnologia
proporciona uma um aumento exponencial
do conhecimento e o acesso a esse
conhecimento então a gente fica na
cabeça com com buracos negros matéria
escura no espaço é clonagem
a manipulação genética
enfim guerras é [ __ ] risco de
pandemias é tanta complexidade que a
gente até pode pensar que a que que esse
recrudescimento
5º da adar dos fundamentalismos se deve
a isso uma tentativa de de ver o mundo
com mais simplicidade não olha crianças
absolutas o bem eo mal né então vamos lá
não por favor simplifica
mas pra esses eu tenho péssimas notícias
porque só vai piorar
é é o o o esse fundador da revista wired
que uma revista que trata de temas de
vanguarda em uma entrevista muito
recente para cientistas ele ele diz o
seguinte que os próximos 30 anos vão vão
provocar vão ser de outubro de
modificações tão radicais que os últimos
20 que a gente viveu e que acha que
houve mudanças radicais que esses aí vão
ser brincadeira
uma bobagem palha 2 diante do que vem aí
na nossa frente e o e se estes
cientistas veículos vaiou drexel ver
músicas entre outros que estuda o futuro
estudo os vetores do desenvolvimento da
tecnologia no futuro eles a apontam um
futuro bastante impressionante
pelo menos pra mim é por isso uma coisa
que todo mundo já sabe que o computador
vai sair das telas e celular com tela
não essa coisa da internet de todas as
coisas
tudo está nas paredes tudo vai estar
conectado os objetos vão estar
conectados e conectados conosco entre si
enfim um mundo que a gente pode imaginar
bem diferente fora isso o homem criou já
não é uma espécie não biológica é com
uma inteligência muito mais eficiente do
que a nossa é do que a dele próprio e
que consegue se auto reparar nela que se
corrige então e essa espécie pe
segundo eles ainda é em 40 anos em 40
anos é muito próximo e lepra próxima
geração é essa essa espécie vai ter
aumentado 1 bilhão de vezes sobre a
terra quer dizer amaremos com boas
seremos amigos robôs é uma coisa natural
a gente conviver com essa outra
espécie e como diz um cientista francês
tomara que eles não acham que a gente é
comida bom vai haver vida na realidade
vitor virtual não sei quem viu avatar
mas aquela coisa fantástica se fechar o
olho e viver outra vida o metro
diferente do que já acontece com aqueles
jogos de rpg que tem no computador ea
século arso e agora essa moeda bito com
ele já começa a ter isso mas que vai ser
realmente a realidade virtual vai haver
uma vida e o recurso vai eu falo da
imortalidade é uma coisa né assim ele
toma se ele tá fazendo esperança consigo
próprio retoma que 150 pílulas por dia
para ver se impede o envelhecimento da
aben brana da célula enfim ea e e e o
dessa maneira quer dizer impedindo o
envelhecimento das células
o transferindo o cérebro enfrentar um
robô desses enf
é isso aí muda tudo né porque muda a
nossa visão do mundo porque o eixo de
visão de mundo que nós temos é a nossa
finitude nessa coisa de não não tem vai
caber todo mundo vai nascer gênio vai
enfim um problema realmente imenso mas
ele jura que em 40 anos está resolvido e
o 20 e gente eles não são videntes nem a
de vinhos é pessoa que estuda mesmo são
matemáticos e cientistas da computação e
tal e o 20 fala de uma singularidade e
singularidade um conceito da física
quântica passado clube parar pra nós nem
pra vida biológica porque na física
quântica esse conceito usado de buracos
negros tse quando a coisa é tão tão
incompreensível para nós é tão além do
que a gente pode entender que aí está
não dá para prever nada bom e aí como é
que a gente está preparando nossas
crianças para viver nesse mundo pra
fazer e esse futuro e é contra a escola
e aí a gente vê que há uma sala de aula
vitoriana igual uma sala de hoje em dia
nem de dodô mês passado a escola estava
incomodada com isso mas ela também não
sabe
muito que fazer mas ela continua lá com
as suas
é a aula de jesus 50 50 minutos um dos
alunos atrás dos outros qualquer um de
nós chega qualquer escola a gente
reconhece há aqui uma escola
é evidente que as honrosas exceções quem
sabe até no rio existem suas exceções e
que bom que na escola pública porque eu
tô falando escola pública não tô falando
escola particular a a navios gente que
são propostas diferentes mas é mas ainda
são experimentais a maior parte das
pessoas não confia nisso mas essa essas
crianças vão fazer o que com a sua vida
e aí porque elas mudaram completamente a
escola mudou as crianças mudaram edição
os nativos digitais que a gente sabe e
imersos crescem imersos em bsb de saber
mexer em tudo e hoje até existe um
estudo da biologia da msd como a casa 7
e com crianças de 9 a 13 anos no ano
passado que mostram que essas crianças
já são mais do que nativos ele chama de
geração f5 gf 5 é porque eles é é enfim
e f5 é a tecla do computador que no
inferno é que realiza e ap eles são full
time eo fk z conectados o tempo inteiro
feed atualiza o tempo todo a coisa
contratação sempre atualizando tem foco
cinco dizer que as crianças não têm foco
não tem foco pra escola
agora o que interessa pra estudar essa
profunda tem filtro sabem achar o que
presta naquilo tudo a gente não sabe mas
quase não eles sabem achar e tem
flexibilidade eles abordam o
conhecimento por todos os lados não são
como nós
eu então imigrante imigrante digital que
só sei de uma coisa depois a outras ou
mono tarefeiras fazer mas não vamos
aprofundar aqui ele está a bordo
qualquer lado não tem aquela coisa não o
pré requisito não deu ainda o a física
uno pode dar dois então aquela coisa que
a escola ainda tem de matemática uma
temática dos quais fantástico isso na
época e que é matemática 1
o marcador já perguntei nada que julieta
shama de geometria que um chama da coisa
que é porque a criança fica não é
professor diferente que acho que outra
coisa
é uma troca uma coisa é 2 outra coisa
porque é bem recortado né esse
fantástico outra coisa ainda é prática
as centenárias é prova a semana de
provas não pode ser prova fora da semana
de prova
entendo ficar por dois décimos dois
décimos fiquei por um ponto como deixou
de aprender um ponto naquele ano um
faltou um inacreditável
bom bom essas crianças então chegam e e
e sabe essas coisas escola é surreal
para eles né
o que é isto e tudo descontextualizado
neto de contextualizado nada tem pé no
real no real dele cedendo nenhum real né
bom então a escola vai ter que se
acostumar a a alargar de algumas crenças
que é tipo monopólio do conhecimento ela
que legaliza os conhecimentos do diploma
não ela vai perder e isso porque se
aprende muito fora da escola hoje ele é
muito mais do que na escola talvez né
as escolas podem ser diferentes e isso é
um pouco assim as pessoas ficam aflitas
porque não tem que oferecer
oportunidades iguais
eu acho que hoje com essa escola com o
currículo igual de doha porque acho ido
em qualquer lugar é ela já não é igual é
mentira que a gente oferece uma
igualdade de oportunidade evidente uma
escola no interior do matar na floresta
não é igual à escola há a ação a sul e é
completamente diferente
o o tempo do aluno é muito mais rápido
a educação a distância e presencial à
distância sendo encarada como o de 2ª
classe né
e que não é a mesma coisa é só porque
tem que ser proposta de forma de uma
forma diferente um veículo sob medida
tudo esses alunos muito diferente é bom
a tava vendo na verdade um dos
paradigmas
uma ruptura uma corrida de continuidade
não é uma lacuna geracional normal e
natural
o mundo luta essa tecnologia realmente
provocou uma uma mudança de paradigma a
gente tem que ir mudança de paradigma
coisa dolorosa galileu quase foi pra
fogueira para joão mudança de paradigma
então pra nóis é é muito difícil pensar
nisso e vamos ter que pensar em largar a
nossa querida e amada escola clássica
que todos freqüentamos a tudo isso
enciclopedismo né que faz nos faz
eruditos achamos a a agente acha né
é para uma escola completamente
diferente abandonar essa abordagem
escola etar uma escola que que provoque
o pensamento inovador que propunha
problemas reais não é problema de
matemática não há problemas reais às
crianças
então você olha só eu fiz um quadro de
que conhecimento serão necessários que
me passaram pela cabeça que eu acho que
são os problemas que devem ser dados às
crianças
então todo mundo pode pode acrescentar
coisas aqui mudathir em botar outro e
alimentação no mundo é um problema água
potável não é a nano a nanotecnologia
essa coisa de entrar coisas mínimas na
gente
háháhá a manipulação genética o
aquecimento global a sustentabilidade do
planeta
a energia que de energia robótica ética
isso tudo aí tem que se discutir a
questão ética então é é um kia é o que a
gente pode propor porque não tem mais a
matéria com um currículo mínimo que já é
péssimo nome mínimo um currículo mínimo
de física de química história geografia
não é mais assim você vai abordar tudo
isso a escola não precisa dar porque
está nos sites de busca
tudo né e as crianças estão se
comunicando entre si num não precisa
disso que precisa propor problemas com
as crianças já estão avançando um pouco
aqui pra que elas resolvam problemas na
vida real
agora como eu sou de uma geração que eu
eu eu logo digo vocês que talvez tenha
escorregado aqui mas eu ainda acho
alguma coisa deve ser deve permanecer na
escola antiga e é lógica é ensinar
lógica aí sim debater e discutir lógica
porque porque o pensamento humano e
lógico e deve ser lojas para se
comunicar tem que se ter que ser lógico
e até para pensar coisas inovadoras você
tem que ter alguma lógica eu diria mais
as lógicas que são diversas lógicas e à
matemática que o pensamento matemática
que realmente encaminha gente pra cá a
meditação nessa coisa fantástica de
planetas comprovados matematicamente
quer dizer ninguém nunca viu é
fantástico eu acho então eu fico com
isso aí ainda segurando então que as
competências necessárias para viver
neste século é identificar e resolver
problemas e identificar problemas porque
não existe chegar e dá pra criança lá é
o trânsito no rio de janeiro não recorda
ela tem que aprender a recortar os
problemas do trânsito rio de janeiro
coisa grande imagem então trânsito onde
na gávea o trânsito ao ano na marquês de
são vicente e o transfor sei lá no
horário das escolas
ela aprendeu a recortar vários grupos
que discutem o problema traz outros
problemas e assim elas vão em busca do
conhecimento que está todo na internet
não está todo lá nos goggles a vida como
eu digo e se precisar de aula primeiro
professor tá lá ele continua ali e tem
hoje universidade de kansas deve
conhecer que é a umas aulas aulas assim
trigonometria será o cm o cosseno então
lá dá nas aulas da universidade khan
outra sala do quarto e do texas e
milhões de outras coisas que estão lá
aquele conhecimento já bem assim esse
fim que a escola dá agora que já está
dentro do computador ea alfabetização
científica é fundamental para esse
próximo século é o século da ciência
ciência a sinergia com a tecnologia está
avançando brutalmente a questão da
sustentabilidade do planeta que é
urgente é um pensamento divergente a uma
realidade planetária você tem que pensar
no todo né a bomba metodologia de
problema já disse a vocês é realmente
propor problemas que não são problemas
matemáticos mais uma vez e várias coisas
a equipe trabalhar em times essa coisa
da escola hoje que todo indivíduo ao
atrás do outro pode olhar o olho pode
falar com o outro e isso acabou né a
questão do trabalhante lhes para
resolver os problemas
enfim vocês viram ali eu já passei o fim
a sala de aula clássica do ó ea gente
não tem sala de sete anos sala de 8 ante
sala de 19 anos e olha se você tem sete
e pergunta da sala de oito professores
que diz só o ano que vem querido
agora não bom então a escola foi feita
pra pensar
ela foi feita pra gente pra espécie
humana usar sua capacidade de pensar e
nata de ginástica essa capacidade é
maravilhosa e pra ela pra saber o que
fazer com as informações processar e
analisar sintetizar a equipe produzir
conhecimento para a solução de problemas
que essa geração vai viver com esses
problemas
então pra fazer um mundo melhor para
elas precisam saber é discutir seus
problemas e à discussão de valores que é
uma coisa fundamental
aí eu volto um pouco a questão da cidade
que a canção nessa cidade a escola tem
que abrir seus muros todos e falar com a
cidade a cidade com ela colaborar e
interagir as parcerias né as crianças
levam a cidade e suas soluções para os
problemas e acompanham aquilo nas
instâncias que for então e elas são
essas crianças não vão ser cidadãos um
dia na vida elas são agora então agora
tem pequenos elas convivem com a escola
elas têm que cuidar dos espaços da
escola do esporte da cidade ea cidade
tem que oferecer espaços saudáveis e
inteligentes que essas crianças e jovens
e até já existe aliás é no subúrbio
praça do conhecimento e navios no
conhecimento que são espaços conectados
para as crianças no subúrbio que eu acho
o espetáculo isso já está acontecendo
que bom né
a bom e eu vou terminar falando disso aí
ética
as pessoas confundem moral com ética e
tão bem enfim vou dizer o seguinte moral
você responde à pergunta o que devo
fazer é mais coercitiva
a ética é como eu quero viver mais viver
uma vida digna
uma vida que faça sentido uma vida
interessante e isso aí é que as crianças
têm que discutir agora na escola porque
todas essas modificações da realidade é
preciso dizer que se eu pode se produzir
uma criar uma vida uma espécie estranha
no laboratório pode não pode ser que se
começar a discutir isso e que vida eles
vão viver e que mundo vão deixar o
conhecimento a gente não encolhe ele a
gente não impede mas a gente tem que ver
é que conhecimento a gente vai
desenvolver uma coisa meio complicada
isso mas é o mundo deles eles têm que
discutir isso está obrigada